hey guys i want to remind you about the
show i'm doing saturday april 10th
it's at 6 30 p.m specific time
i'm doing a live dumb people town with
dan van kirk and the sklar brothers
it's the honey dumb there is a limited
edition poster available with proceeds
going to
the charity i work with outreach through
the arts uh with at-risk youth in the
santa monica police department
all four of us are going to sign it
we're going to be highlighting
some dumb ass low lights okay tickets
and posters are available
at danielvankirk.com where you can
search dumb people town
on eventbrite this episode of the
honeydew is brought to you by
upstart raycon me undies and skillshare
more on that later let's get into the
duke
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
uh thank you for your support the
youtube community continues to grow
please subscribe you're getting audio on
monday video on tuesday
and if you'd like another episode a week
my patreon is the honeydew with y'all
where i'm highlighting the lowlights
with y'all
and y'all have some [ __ ] stories i
tell i i'm speechless
for once the stories i am hearing and
getting back i knew we would get wild
stuff but there's just no way to predict
what you guys
are bringing so look it's five bucks a
month i know that's a lot of money for
people right now but if you're in for
the long haul you can sign up for a year
you'll get over a month
of free episodes all right um santa
monica music center where i record here
i want to tell you about
the program we're doing outreach through
the arts with the at-risk youth in the
santa monica police department i'm just
very excited about it we're teaching
kids about podcasting cameras everything
that goes into a free podcast
that isn't free to bring out there for
you guys to [ __ ] all over every week in
the comments section
so uh very excited to work with these
kids you'll be hearing me talk more
about that want to promote it and
if you or someone you know is looking to
take music lessons santa monicamusic.com
you use the code honeydew uh they'll
sign
they'll give you a free lesson when you
sign up for a package all right
that's it that's the biz uh we're over
here highlighting the low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers as i always say today's
guest is back i'm very excited to have
the one and only dr drew you all yeah
speaking of low lights here i am look
and i love that they [ __ ] all over you
too
i did one episode which we're not going
to talk about code yeah
we did one episode when i actually had
it yeah did one episode with giannis
pappas about his experience in mind and
the tale of two coronas about how he
almost died
yeah and we were relatives i still don't
have my smell right what are they gonna
[ __ ] on what's the problem they're sick
of hearing about it i was like this is
just our story like this is what
happened i had it too so let's let's
now you and i get it right our stories
you kindly came on uh
after dark my show and talked about this
stuff so listen man i've looked up to
you for
so long it's a pleasure to sit across
from you and
at any point um you losing weight yeah
i'm
i'm eating better right now i'm trying
to do better by myself i have a
five-phase plan when i became a single
dad and unfortunately health should have
been at the top but mental health was
more
than physical i'd rather at this point
in my life dr drew
i'm not trying to work on my abs or
anything i'm trying to work on me okay
you know what i'm saying well you
started therapy after the first
time i'm yeah you got me onto the i i
had this
real quick promote everything you'd like
good doctor
it's all at drdo.com just go to
doctordrew.com it's all there
so my daughter almost got hit by a car
and it unleashed
this anxiety that apparently had just
been lying
dormant for decades that i didn't even
know was in their
building or you know working its way up
and that made me just
in a sense lose it i i and and two
things that stood out were
i became incredibly um scared of heights
and i mean realistica in a plane
that looks cartoonish to me but but
three four stories
anxiety can generalize you can start to
move into other areas and sort of
amplify other phobias and things
it was that and it was flying it was and
wasn't even the landing it was the take
off
once we were up we're good yeah and it
got to me and you said that when you had
reconnected with your father
some things like that had started to
shift for you is what you had told me
uh in my therapy yes
yes in therapy but but i had fear of
flying before i had a horrible anxiety
disorder for a long time i mean you fly
non-stop well how did you get over it uh
for a while there was bad
and uh it just it's one of these things
i'll tell you what happened
the way for your flying goes it's
usually somebody who doesn't have it and
then it kind of comes on
and then it goes away very suddenly okay
good yeah you're ready for it i'm ready
to go
i had to fly this was
we did some crazy promotion back when
ricky rackman was my co-host on love
live here
he was going to get married in las vegas
he was my partner on the show at the
time
and julio iglesias was going to be the
officiator
and so he sent his plane actually to go
home
we got on his plane and it was like
flying on a magikarp it was unbelievable
yeah and it was so
comfortable and i could talk to the
pilot and i could see it i see what's
going on i was able to fly
without anxiety and so my head just went
oh you can do this and don't have to be
in a
state it's possible to it's just like it
was like almost like a learning like the
anxiety just
shut off and that was it i got over it
yeah i thompson
took me yeah so what was bad what would
it be
taking off and landing were terrible and
some it got generated i didn't want to
talk about it because it's gonna make
you
worse but people dropped a few things
here and there like
i remember in college a friend of mine
was going do you ever look out the plane
window and see how those wings look so
flimsy that was
that kind of thinking or i was sitting
next to a pilot once
getting this all to college and the guy
goes yeah this once you get up you're
fine but getting
40 tons off the ground that's dangerous
and i'm like oh great
[Laughter]
i used to love the feeling of shooting
down that runway and taking off it felt
like a rock star i do know
and uh when when segura took me on we
were on this privacy i'm already like we
were on this private jet that
was coming back from nebraska in a
snowstorm like here we go [ __ ] richie
valens here
comes yeah he's like well we have to
upgrade to a a
a bigger jet that can handle this and
i'm like oh you know i don't like can we
just
so we get on the thing and we take off
and you're right it felt like it felt
like this just magikarp
lift up and go and then i said why i'm
talking to the pilot so i'm like
where's the tur why is this so smooth
they said we fly a we fly above the
turbulence i'm like huh they're like we
fly 10 000 feet
above commercial airlines i'm like
there's nothing up here like nothing and
that did it
and it's fine i was like this is oh we
zoomed and i was like okay
so yeah it's you like you can't do it
it's like you manage your anxiety and
goes away it dissipates it sort of
distinguishes
but in my anxiety what i was talking
about my anxiety was it was not
connecting with my father which was the
interesting
thing you said there i thought it was it
was connecting now well listen guys you
like this
dr freud it was it was it was connecting
with my feelings
and uh i'm wondering if your thing is
maybe more connecting with
father which is kind of interesting but
my mom is what it was with me yes
for sure and so i was i was distanced
from my feelings and all i could feel
was anxiety
and i got connected up and that was with
my work man it
well you changed me because you sent me
to a therapist you said have you ever
done emdr and i said you said you would
know and i said no i haven't done that
i've turned you've met lana yeah
she goes all the same person that's
great um several people i know do as a
matter of fact
therapist yeah yeah and that she is
great and
i never you know i'm blown away by the
amount of people who've messaged me and
said i've started therapy because your
show i've had a couple of professors say
that this is required listening now and
i'm like
well i am beyond flattered and just i
love it it makes me feel
part of it is that that um you know if
you can do it i
i don't i mean this in a in the most
positive way possible if you can do it
anybody can do it in the sense leave me
you're right
but not in the sense that it's hard to
do and since it you're the guy that
everyone expects just sort of
muscle through and not not get into this
stuff and here look at all the benefits
you've derived from it
i can't get over it yeah i never set out
to do i just
i didn't even know there was there were
people that outside of my family and
close friends that would laugh at their
trauma and take real
deep dark shots at it you know i i say
all the time one day a friend of mine
just out of nowhere was like hey ryan
your dad's still dead
right and it [ __ ] still makes me like
everything that's going on in that makes
me laugh so hard i still did
so one thing i have not been able to do
though in my life and i know
why well i shouldn't say i know why but
i know where it originates is
to have a successful relationship so not
only do you have a successful marriage
you guys are banging it out like what
three four nights a week yeah
i mean it's it's crazy and you've been
together for how long married for 30.
together more like 38. insane
because i tell this story about this
older black guy
named john lewis that i worked with at
ups shout out to ups baltimore
primary one joe avenue and he took me
under his wing and trained me a little
bit and just
he was reggie lewis's uncle from the
celtics who have passed away and i'm
enamored by this guy because
he's just an older black guy and anytime
an older black man would talk to me i'm
listening to
everything they have to [ __ ] say i
didn't grow up with a dad after 16. i'm
looking for knowledge
in any nook and cranny i can get it and
this guy's training me on the job and
we're talking one night and he tells me
he's married like you 30 years or
whatever and it's friday night four in
the morning he's gonna go home and he's
like i'm gonna [ __ ] my wife
and he said it with and i was like god
with energy yeah
a lot of purpose more in the morning and
i'm like what's the secret and he said
ryan you gotta make that [ __ ] pop
and he screamed and i was like oh the
secret to a long jeffy
is [ __ ] popping so are you what's your
version of [ __ ] popping doctor
what is your secret you gotta want to
pop the [ __ ] that's my secret
you understand
if that's something like in you then
it's probably gonna stay there it's
probably gonna stay with you
so if you you feel that if that passion
is there at the beginning
you can sustain that yeah it really has
got to be there though i think it's very
important i'm not saying
that all relationships have to have that
but it's a very steady glue that if
you've got
really helps okay yeah and but you're
talking about both partners it can't be
one person can't be one and one's like
yeah but there's many many versions of
that right some per some
the receptive partner might like the
passion coming from another person and
feel gratified by it and
her passion may respond to him you know
i mean it doesn't have to come equally
in the same way from both people
but it does have to fit together with
the same intensity if that makes sense
it does
absolutely yeah so i i mean look my
parents had a failed marriage and i'm
sort of that was in the same pattern my
dad and mom split they got back together
and tried it again
so did i well for the longest time it's
always been in any relationship i've
been in it's like oh we're not a good
fit together what
but i never i shouldn't say i never i
got there quicker than most people i was
like
man you're the common denominator in all
your [ __ ]
i realize that i'm the common
denominator in all my relationships and
i realized
i haven't had success in any long-term
relationship not one
and sometimes i'm certainly at fault for
doing
dumb [ __ ] i've cheated before or i've
just neglected or whatever it's been
but i wanted to learn what i'm bringing
to the table and i'm learning what i'm
bringing to the table and now
i practice so much more you know
gratitude and
and being present um and i learned that
from being a parent too like hey man you
got to do that over here too
big difference yeah it's a huge
difference and and also just
you know helping out with these kids
like all these things that ways i can
help other people
is beneficial i see some of them in me
you know i'm like man i wish i would
have had like alana in my life when i
was 16 or
17. i feel like i do feel like
i've been stunted in a way um i say this
my father died at 16 my mom's gone i
feel like it's stunned to me 10 years
in certain aspects mom split the family
early on
she was did you go back and talk to her
since i mean when i turned
40 yeah 41 yeah but um not since 18
you know but what was i saying
all the [ __ ] you you've brought yeah
everything i've brought to it
comes from these things and
i you know it goes all the way back to
the beginning and i feel these traumas
and i learned that like
the end of a breakup is you're feeling
something you've been conditioned i'm
feeling these feelings of funerals and
all these other things again are coming
back and it's just so overwhelming
um and then having a daughter definitely
calmed me down
like oh calmed you down yeah i knew it
would i really i hoped i had a daughter
because i i grew up with brothers
everyone's aggressive it's all
testosterone
give me something a little different and
she does she makes me look at things
you're saying men and women are
different how dare you cancel this guy
cancel
but i i've never you know i'm i feel
like i'm
good at a lot of things i feel like i
don't know parenting's a long-term game
i'm good i say it all the time right now
i'm doing a good job now yeah i know in
two years i can [ __ ] up and do something
so it also changes too at each
developmental stage it's a whole
different task
so right now it's good i'm a good i feel
like just learn to bite a hole in your
goddamn lip yeah that's something
that's the real thing i say all the time
i'm a i'm a smart ass by nature and then
a professional comedian on top of it to
shut my [ __ ] mouth
is so hard and i'm working it's an
important skill
it is it's it's and i've learned to
listen and not be so reactive
i learned the more you shut up and let
someone talk the more they'll [ __ ]
say and give to you yeah
i was so quick to want to have
everything right away and get resolved
and now i realize that most of the time
if you sit
they'll tell you everything and then the
[ __ ] will take care of itself it's
taking me a long time i was saying it
stunted me by 10 years that's what i was
saying yeah
emotionally financially i didn't know
anything about money i just knew
save it spend it i didn't know how to
make my money work for me and all hell i
didn't even have it to give to make it
work for me you know
and but as far as street smarts and
hustle
and grind i feel like i'm i'm fine on
that i'm here on that
but learning about relationships money
how to do this how to do that i'm behind
yeah more subtle stuff yeah um
well we're that you know human almost
nothing is more complicated than human
relationships
which which is why when people start
talking about polyamory and that stuff i
just i just keep saying look
there are armies of people out there to
try to help two people have a good
relationship
you bring another one my head comes off
it's i i can't keep it all straight
it's too much it is too much this circle
of people i've been putting around me
professionally and personally has been
nothing but positive
it's taken a while to get that to cut
those you know
anchors off the ship and let that [ __ ]
go
um but i see the more and more i
surround myself with good people
more and more good things are happening
well of course right right that that's a
that's another good axiom just uh
anybody that's listening take that one
home put that one in the bank that's a
good one it's taking me a while you know
this person i feel sorry for we're still
talking to this guy about he's still in
the same place since high school like
you got to go bro
you're not even working on yourself if
you don't work on yourself you don't
bring anything to the table
i can't [ __ ] with you it is really it's
frustrating and sad definitely
i'm almost like that makes me crazy
right yeah i hate that
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor upstart if you
have
multiple credit cards you know that
tracking multiple balances due dates and
website logins can be stressful upstart
makes things simple
with one monthly payment in one place
upstart
is the fast and easy way to get a
personal loan to pay off your debt
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards whether you're
consolidating higher interest debt or
you're funding personal expenses over a
half a million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment i know a lot of you out
there have
that's why they keep coming back because
it works you guys have hit me up and i'm
so glad
uh that it's working out for you it's
saving you money
and time and upstart will find smarter
rates with trusted partners
because they assess more than just your
credit score with the five minute online
rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
from one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars
you can get approved the same day and
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day
if debt is taking over your life it's
time to get a fresh start
with upstart find out how upstart can
lower your monthly payments today when
you go to upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com honeydew
don't forget to use our url
to let them know we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor is raycon now
i don't know about you but i feel like
i'm
always looking at a screen now more than
ever especially and whether you're an
avid news watcher or if you're in
serious need of a distraction
unplugging yourself is easier said than
done one of my favorite ways
to rest my eyes and still get the
content i'm itching for
is by putting in my raycom wireless
earbuds and listening
to something great like the honeydew
whether you're catching up on your
favorite news podcast bringing an audio
book or powering through your workout
with the pumped up playlist
a pair of racons in your ears can make
all the difference uh
you know look i they've been sponsoring
us for a while and again
thank you guys for supporting raycons
they're great a bunch of you hit me up
about them i'm telling you
they're affordable they sound amazing i
use them all the time
back when i was on the road i only use
raycon to travel can't wait to get back
out there do it again if i'm walking
exercising
even in here just working around the
office boom
raycons all day there's no dangling
wires or stems that get in your way here
raycons come in a range of stylish color
ways but also
with a comfortable in-ear fit for a more
discreet look raycons are built to
perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction
and bluetooth depairs quickly and
seamlessly and with enough battery life
for six
hours of play time you can unplug for a
while and the best part
raycom makes great sound accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds starting
at half the price
of other premium audio brands raycon is
offering 15
off all their products from my listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com slash honeydew
that's it you'll get 15 off your entire
raycon order
so feel free to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15 percent off at byraycon.com
honeydew by raycon dot com slash
honeydew
now let's get back to the do so what do
you attribute talk to me
about some things did your parents i
can't remember were they together
yeah so was my wife were they in were
they in love or they stayed again they
say to you okay
well i couldn't tell i i they were so
emotionally sort of not
there for me that uh i i i don't know
what to call it uh they they certainly
i they probably want it to be together i
think
but i wouldn't say that it was a bad
enough relationship that i used to think
to myself i used to fear marriage
because i just like well
when it comes to get you have your fun
you work you get married then you die
that was sorry i always saw it like
there was no no
enjoyment coming after marriage and i
was shocked to find it otherwise
really surprised um but yeah they had
they did not have like what i'd call a
healthy relationship
so but they stay together and so did my
wife and her
parents okay and and i think that script
of the parents staying together did have
an influence on us
it's it's it makes you not consider
divorce when trouble hits
you just it's not on the table you're
just sorry how are we going to get
through this how are we going to deal
with this what's going on what
what's the problem yeah and you don't
think you know you i mean
if it's something catastrophic you may
say it or talk about it
but it's not really on the table it take
a lot to put that on the table
so did that inspire you to want them
have a healthy relationship where you
want to stay together
i mean is that something you openly
discuss or is it just something that's
inherent in your
relationships what we discuss is more
about the importance of building
family and being a family and having
that
well there's two things you don't that
young people don't think about when you
get married
you're not just building a relationship
you're building a life together it's a
life uh and if you have children you're
building a foundation
for your children's lives as well as as
the part of the sort of the central
point of this thing we call
family and people don't like do a lot of
family building these days
you know what i mean yes and uh and
that's sort of weird
that's what humans are sort of designed
for
is to have these extended family systems
that are that support each other
yeah i just had a conversation with my
brother about that like yo
you remember what we come from you
remember how we grew up
have let's make sure everybody's talking
and checking in because if something
happens to us our kids
are going to need to be they're stuck
here right let them know each other
yeah so all right you're the most
busiest person on the damn planet you
have
three kids where do you guys find time
how do you carve it out throughout your
relationship let's talk about
early years how where are you finding it
for the relationship
yeah where are you finding time to have
sex and and one-on-one time
we did not have a lot of stuff but at
the beginning i was working 20 hours a
day seven years a week it was i don't
know how my wife put up with it frankly
she's a very independent person and and
she was very quickly
consumed with babies right we had
triplets and so her thing was 20 hours a
day too
so we just we went into survival mode
for about
10 years 10 maybe eight eight years okay
that's well
for sure it's a full survival mode and
eight to ten and at the end and i
started therapy
in in there when the kids were about one
two and why
why did you start well we had a child
that needed uh a brain surgery
and we had a very traumatic experience
he's now in law school and killing it
and stuff so it all turned out fine but
it was
very scary that went down and my anxiety
disorder became
insane i guess i was nuts to deal with
and i remember
my susan called me at work one day i was
at the psychiatric hospital and she goes
hey hey you know you need to see a
therapist and she called to tell me that
i thought well that's kind of
interesting
and i and i was busy as f and i would
run around go yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah i know i really would
help me with my work i'm gonna i'm gonna
do that one day hey
you need to do it and it literally set a
chill down my spine
i got the message she's like do it or
else cause you're not this is not
working for me
this sort of was in the message like
you're you're losing it
it's hard to be around i mean it was all
so much packed into that yeah
call somebody and i i put the phone and
i called somebody immediately
and uh best thing i ever did and
what so three kids
non-stop hours how do you do it now then
where are you
now it's great now we work together we
travel together
she's producing all of my digital stuff
and she has really great
she's really good at it and she has
purpose and feels good about it
um so it hasn't always been this way
we're together all the time now almost
the point where she's like
a little too much don't you want to go
dinner with ryan tonight
with the you know corolla or something
uh
and uh but it's been great i think and
so
you know i i feel like we're in a weird
way maybe close to an hour and we're in
a weird way
really yeah and that's after 30 years
it's weird
what do you think is yours okay it
doesn't feel like that's insane 30 years
it's just it's all
it's all like compressed i mean in our
heads and she we both of us we do talk
about this
we're kind of experiencing time in the
same way we both feel like we're yeah
24.
you know we were just you know same as
where we were 26
28 whatever same same which is
weird and good night lovely you know to
have that renewing
what would you if you're being honest
about yourself what would you say your
weaknesses are
my weaknesses
i got lots of them uh the anxiety stuff
is always bad
the uh i have a i'm i'm
although i've compensated for this
you'll hear this from other people who
you
don't want to don't doesn't seem like
this is true i am very shy
i am super shy if i don't have a purpose
in what i'm doing i like i just
completely withdraw
i i get that okay i'm not a chatty kathy
i've never been there it's worse than
that i can't i can't walk in a room and
feel comfortable oh really i have
something to do
when i walk in um i
uh i at one point
i feel like have to work at rigorous
honesty i mean i am
rigorously honest i i had a tendency to
exaggerate
and my wife used to call me out on it
and and now i i just
i i always try to live by and i didn't
always do this i i want to live by
uh kant's moral imperative you know act
as though all of your
actions are a a moral principle in other
words
whether somebody sees you or not act as
though somebody's looking at you and
judging you
no matter what i mean these days
everyone's got you on camera yeah
but but no but it's yes it's the right
thing it's being
a good person i read that um what's the
quote i read the other day in somebody's
toilet uh
character is doing something for someone
when no one's watching
exactly something and that i i
rigorously live by them okay
uh and and honesty is part of that too
um and i do and and over time it has
become it becomes very easy very fast
interestingly once once you adopt that
as your your
just iron clad strategy it becomes habit
you know i
i do a lot of listen a lot of podcasts
on uh virtue philosophy and stuff and
they always talk about what do you do if
you find a wallet full of money i go i
i don't care i would give i would find
the guy i would give it back i don't
care i don't i don't care
what if it's a million dollars like no
i'll find them when i come back
i do it
but that's but those are the kinds of
thought experiments you got to do with
yourself
and you know so when these things happen
you've got to be
and and stoic philosophy has helped me
with that too do you ever talk to ryan
holiday
no good guy he might come in here that's
going to be coming all right
um okay other weaknesses i've got um
i am actually not uh
sturdy physically and probably not
emotionally either
uh what do you mean you know covet
destroyed me i was destroyed
and and i'm still i still it's walking
up these stairs still tired
yeah yeah i'm not crazy dirty i i i
i wish i could be a navy seal and be but
i would have been out quick
because i just i'm not that i
genetically i'm not
sturdy and so i have to work at uh
pushing myself
which i find again also becomes really
easy after you've done it for a while
um but i you know can get sick really
easily and i get tired real easily and
[ __ ] that i wish i didn't
and i have to have to you know push
weights all the time
uh and work out or i just completely
regress in a day or two
because i'm just not sturdy yeah and
that's frustrating
um other weaknesses
uh i think i can be irritable like
particularly
after covants and personality changes
where i was more irritable
and um i don't dig that
yeah and what would you say are your
wife's strengths
she's she is sturdy the exact and that's
why i sort of know i'm not i'm not as
sturdy as she is she's like
super human uh and that way like
just doesn't get sick doesn't it just
just con
she's like the flux capacitor
whatever the [ __ ] it was it's still
gonna work
and i i think you know when you look at
how our attractions work in
our body as males you know one of the
things you're not
aware of you just like something you
know you just do i want that
but i think one of my motivators around
attraction where it was
you know that kind of um genetic
superiority
because i was really i was crazy
attracted to her like couldn't can stand
it
um didn't know that you know that she
was this
specimen genetically um she has
extraordinarily good this is going to
seem like a very specific thing but
capacity for sequences explain that
like like she can figure out or follow
directions
on a very complicated production
panel and sound and that's that's all
about sequences
and then remembering the sequences and
being able to adjust where you need to
adjust within those sequences
i see and and absorbs and solves those
kinds of problems
really easier because i got a math brain
a math brain and her brother was a you
know
was a mathematician and one of her son's
a mathematician so that
kind of came through um
[Music]
she's way more beautiful than i am way
i'm too it's she's too good for me
i don't know i hear all the girls call
you daddy all the time
they throw that z on the front of that
doctor they call you sad what does that
mean
am i a zim that may be a zoom too
maybe that's what you guys
no the ladies love you you know it you
know the ladies love you dr drew
so yeah all right here's another
question i want to ask as a doctor who
people look to for advice opinions and
all that stuff what how do you learn
from your mistakes
oh constantly i i i
i this is what people don't understand i
i
look forward to mistakes i look forward
to being wrong that's how my mind
grows that's how i learn things um the
one thing though
when i was you know i taught medicine
for a lot of years
and the one thing i would tell them i go
okay
we would be sitting in icu and i go what
are you going to do because i try not to
bias their decision
show me the literature give me an
example someone yeah someone's in septic
shock and you want to use a certain
antibiotic or you want to go after the
cytokine activation that you just
learned about because of covid
show me the literature give me give me
the give me the literature that you're
upon which you're based in that judgment
i'll look at the literature
and i said fine and you make your
decision you know if the literature's
flawed and you didn't see it
you're going to hear from me but i'll
look at your literature and see what you
know what you're making your decision on
good good um and then give me your logic
and what you expect and what do you
think is going to happen here
now what do you know this this is where
i got harsh what if you're wrong
what if or what if it doesn't work for
whatever reason what are you going to do
and if they if they would just look at
me blank or i don't know i would
i would lose it i said i i wanted your
backup plan
no problem making a mistake no problem
what's your backup pan
that back up and you maybe need two or
three you better think that through
and have that when i ask you what you're
gonna do you better be able to tell me
and then tell me why so i always kind of
think that way
so i do have backup plans i always i i
and i don't mind making
errors i'm not going to be perfect i'm
not there's no way well i watched
everything with covet and then you go
you own it right away yeah people still
going to say that
you know let me ask you this as
as frenetic as i see you all these do
you work better
under stress or i work better better
calm
or both because i'm feeling like
everything if i'm in icu i'm feel like
okay
yeah you're assessing like this yeah and
then i feel like after that it's a
slower process
here's i i actually think i get a little
high
off spinning lots lots a lot stuff going
on
but i hate the crunch of time
so i hate the idea that i'm spinning and
going and going and
oh [ __ ] there's 10 more things coming
down the pike and and
and i have 20 minutes to do all of it i
hate that if if everything would fall
into line with the schedule
i i i the busier the better
in the given unit of time that i have to
do it it's the stuff that comes
pouring in like you just saw my phone
going up that drives me crazy
that drives me crazy i don't want to be
bothered by other things
when i've allotted some time to do
something else the fact that i'm
you know have time set aside to do three
things at once later
fine that's then i just don't want it
coming in now it bothers me when it when
stuff bleeds in
it's it's tough that's why tough it's
tough to see outpatients in medicine
because you got you got you got another
one sitting outside every 15 minutes
i don't i really don't like that i'll
explain whatever time i need and then
moving to the next thing
what's been your favorite part of
medicine
or the medical field yeah i liked i
really was good in the icu
i like that stuff i like that blood
doesn't gross you out
no i like what's the craziest thing
you've seen in an ico
i can't it's like impossible to come up
with it i've seen you ever save a
motorcycle accident
save yeah yeah you mean like out in the
field anywhere
usually that's got anybody yeah really
oh yeah yeah yeah we get them back
yeah i but i do i don't deal with the
trauma i deal with exotic
medical illnesses and infections and you
know crazy stuff
um and you know it's kind of why i got
into addiction medicine you know because
i
what's that exotic illness that's what
yeah
yeah i mean you know we're talking about
the ebolas and things yeah everybody ls
and everything interesting strokes
syndromes and stuff
and and um but it's kind of why i got an
addiction medicine was i was
moonlighting a psychiatric hospital and
i saw these
i started working on some of the cases
and i saw these young people go from
dying to like amazing they were like
what what happened to them
in in medicine generally you go like
critically ill to chronically ill you
know what i mean you're not you're not
better than you ever knew you could be
and so that's what got me fascinated by
addiction in the first place like wow
these people are dying and they can be
beyond
not just better but better than ever how
incredible
i the human body amazes me i you know i
have friends who
uh especially the opiates that were in
comedy you know and these guys are
telling me they're popping
you know 25 a day and i'm like how how
does
i feel like if i took 25 advil my body
halfway through would be like [ __ ]
and throw it off you're talking about
viking and norco so the average
viking that's that's just 30 to 60 a day
that's the range that you should get
into get the [ __ ] out of here yeah i've
seen a guy do 100 a day
a hundred a day don't they not poop he
they some of them get into that problem
but they'll compensate with all kinds of
laxes and stuff but but i
he went deaf he got where rush limbaugh
got
he so there's his hearing yeah he went
completely deaf like
bone deaf so am i allergic to those my
reactions are i
i literally will sweat i will throw up
i will get hives i will get the itch
here's the great news
you don't have to worry about opiate
addiction that's right i don't know my
doctor's got it on file he's like he
wants to give him to me like no yeah
i i will sign a document refusing but i
actually
i'm so aversive to them that i'm a
little jealous of my patients they love
them so much they must be experiencing
something very nice so is that an
is that a genetic is a genetic reaction
the it's not
i mean the itching and the formication
the that's the
that's the heroin and [ __ ] in there yeah
it's sort of an allergy it's just it's
an
intolerance that people get from it it's
called formication like ants
god i [ __ ] hate it yeah i don't i'm
always the same way but everyone's
different with their stuff
what um all right is a father okay
i'm now my daughter's six years old okay
all right
um we're going through we're getting
ready to go back to school one day a
week
hopefully two at some point god bless um
i think look i'd rather my daughter be a
good friend than a good student
i would i don't want her to be f's and i
don't think she will because the other
day she looked at me and she said dad i
want to be the best student i was like
that's what i'm talking
about let's work on that you got to work
on that it doesn't just come to you
yeah so you know this
homeschooling i'm not qualified to
homeschool um i should not be teaching
children no well these kids i can i
can't teach her
what's going on there yeah but i feel
like kids are missing out on
the hugs oh this is a mess the scene you
know
seeing someone getting treated you
understand that no other country on
earth did this except
i didn't know that is that right the the
most the most stringent lockdowns i
could find anywhere
closed schools for two weeks i'm two
months i'm sorry and that's it that's
it's the longest lockdown i could find
in any country in the world
that i could find now maybe somebody can
check me on that but but that's all i
could find and because they consider it
an essential service that you can't
do that yeah it'll be the case it's the
education it's the
it's the trajectory of the rest of their
lives we're seeing social phobias think
about this
you're supposed to develop the skill of
social interaction at school
you're not going to get that opportunity
and then we're going to tell you stay
away from everybody's six feet away from
everybody and
if you go near it's going to kill your
grandmother it's like
you're nervous around everybody the
social phobia is often
i talked to a psychiatric colleague of
mine who was a as a child psychiatrist
and i and so she's singing a lot of
eight to 15 years ago what are you
seeing she goes
anxiety depression anxiety depression
anxiety depression anxiety depression
it's out of hand it's unbelievable yeah
we have we have destroyed a generation
well done well done we will look at the
school closure as the greatest
misadventure
maybe the century but certainly of this
particular uh
uh pandemic yeah huge misadventure
terrible man
you know this is disgusting what they've
done it is terrible i
i can't ugh i can't
sit there you know when i watch the kid
get in trouble at school
i was like man i don't want to feel like
that fun kid i don't want that to happen
it would put me in check there's a lot
of there's going to be these coveted
kids that are going to be running around
they're going to be just
you know probably pulling their dicks
out and doing everything well
that's what that's all right listen
that's happening and it's happening on
the damn screens that they sent home
yeah
is it really on the screen up 150
just in the sexting and stuff with like
eight-year-olds and nine-year-olds
using the very screens they sent home
can you imagine that no
i mean i can't i'm worried about it i'm
worried about everything i've got a 17
year old i know you got anxiety it's
good
we got anxiety i i talked to him like
you know for us sexually it was if you
got
if you touched a girl over her sweater
if you touched a bouvour you you were
man i'm the king of the world yeah to
get under a sweater over a bra
you know now it's [ __ ] fisting.com
and everything else right off the bat
and i'm trying to teach him like
we have a bigger issue because consent
is everything yeah
but we have to teach our kids that
consent is everything
however you know you got to ask if you
can finish well i'm
gonna ask
i'm writing a book on consent with my
daughter it's coming out in september
are you really
tell me about it i can't i'm not sort of
embargoed and stuff but
but it's it's we know we sort of
condensed uh
not condensed we expanded the notion of
consent to a lot of areas in
relationships
and it's really kind of interesting when
you start thinking about it and really
thinking through what's necessary for
healthy
boundaries and appropriate kinds of
consent requests
kids are confused and my kids you know
my kids are late 20 they're scared
they're scared they you know college was
their college years was me too
and they were like i don't know i don't
want to be seen as yet so they're afraid
to ask they're afraid to sit afraid to
certainly get afraid to drink around a
woman you know
and then interact like you could be it's
very
very crazy let's take a quick break and
tell you about our sponsor me undies me
undies believes that comfort is about
more than what's just touching your skin
it's all about feeling comfortable in
your skin
you're a total badass and what you wear
should only accentuate that fact that's
why me undies not only uses a
sustainable breathable soft as heck
fabric but they also give you
endless styles to choose from it's total
comfort inside
and out i get the box of briefs man i
need something to keep it all up in
there
tight hold it together but i also don't
like it riding up my ass crack you know
what i'm saying
i also don't like regular boxers because
look
i'm a little blessed and it swings you
know what i'm saying so me undies offers
classic colors to ridiculous prints it's
all so you can fully express yourself in
your own unique way me undies are
available in a range of sizes from extra
small
all the way to 4xl never leave your
couch
again with a me undies membership and
monthly subscription
that sends new pairs right to your door
with site-wide savings and exclusive
sales
you'll automatically pay less for
everything meundies has a great offer
for you guys for any first-time
purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping all right meundies
also has their problem free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund or
exchange it no caveats
no questions all right to get your 15
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
honeydew that's meundies.com honeydew
our next sponsor is skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning
with so much to explore real projects to
create and the support of fellow
creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
look i love skillshare i'm able to take
these classes
something i've always wanted to do my
daughter's a picky eater she doesn't eat
a lot of different foods
varieties and i want to introduce her to
them so i'm always throwing steamed
shrimp out i'm always throwing the crab
out she does love crab
i'm always throwing anything i make the
veggies whatever just to try to
introduce her
to new foods and one of the things i
wanted to do before the pandemic hit was
take a cooking class with her so we
could try new things she could see the
ingredients that go into food like look
you like
all these things but it's just in this
thing over here now so
we started taking this class called kids
kitchen cooking from scratch
and it's for kids under five and man
it's been fantastic she loves it i love
it
we get to hang out spend quality time
together and she's getting
you know introduced to new foods so
practice makes progress
advancing toward a goal is achievable
with short lessons
and hands-on projects there's nothing
better than getting better all right
accomplishing growth is extremely
satisfying so do something today
you couldn't do yesterday with classes
designed for real life skillshare
is also incredibly affordable especially
when compared
to pricey in-person classes and
workshops an annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month
all right so uh explore your creativity
at skillshare.com
honeydew get a free trial of premium
membership
all right go try it out you'll have fun
i'm telling you what are you doing at
home right now
that's skillshare.comhoneydo
now let's get back to the do so what
do you think give some advice to these
kids out there now what are excuse me
parents of these teenagers right now
like what do you think
people better talk to a kid especially a
boy because they're just such [ __ ]
horn dogs yeah i mean the girls
these days though are like the new dudes
good good for you but the boys still
have
the boys are just headaches it's
ridiculous so how do we you already i
don't know i don't know what god was
thinking
right you already know your hormones
when we were
at 16. although although they are a
little it's a little for some reason
it's a little toned down a little bit
it's still all there the same motivation
i'm saying how do you
how do you stop that locomotive when
they can just go
right to the internet and see porn oh
that's what they do
how do how do you well you be realistic
about what they're getting access to and
try to limit the screens that's really
all you can do
it's all you can do and and then talk to
them about it because
we don't even know the impact forget on
their sense of what is healthy sexuality
and what a woman is
we don't know what it does to their
brain they're looking at this stuff at 9
10 11
i mean yes if this were some random
primate that we were exposing
extraordinarily stimulating material to
would we be surprised
it would affect their brain development
it's it's we don't know the full
impact of all this yet yeah it's a lot
common it's a lot because that's a lot
common yeah and i don't know i i'm
very concerned about the mental health
in this country
i'm with you i i'm worried about the
kids you know
i also just i couldn't imagine if we had
lost the summer of our lives
a year of our lives in the prime of your
life
you know it'd be one thing over in the
80s like i don't know i don't need 88
[ __ ] 88 but 9 10.
oh yeah man yeah so how would you
how would you come back to little league
if that's you know how would you even do
that
and you have a whole new set everyone's
at different stages of development now
you didn't get the opportunity maybe
your dad took you out and threw the ball
around a couple times you didn't play
any games
how would you just that just that simple
thing
so you i know i talked to a lot of
people from this podcast who suffered
depression as well and you said suicide
is up really what are what age range are
we talking about everybody
everybody but but it's up in young teens
and teens and
particularly young females but that's
been coming for a while it's just
accelerated
the i think the group that got most
affected by this is eight to 15 year
olds i think i think that's the group
that is
really going to be in trouble from this
and we have to
it's not just about getting their
cognitive development back on and their
social development back on track it is
their mental health has got to be dealt
with and
you know it's not that's not a parenting
issue it's a medical issue
parents can be helpful stable
environments attunement
you know just be there presence they
don't they don't need a lot they just
need you present fully emotionally
eye contact you know uh and here's some
advice you know with the females
uh they're more conversant around ten
o'clock at night nine o'clock at night
because the way their homeland cycling
go
so if you have questions open-ended
questions how'd your day go sit down on
the bed
nine o'clock at night at nine o'clock
males uh better particularly if you're a
male
side by side let's go shoot some baskets
and then start talking
driving a car where you're both looking
forward two males are very uncomfortable
eyeball to eyeball
and you're good though we're good right
now
i took my stepson out on uh he was like
will you take me out the drive and i was
like yeah but i'm putting gopros in the
car
yeah and we're about to release it here
in a little bit it's called learner's
permit
and it's him learning about driving but
learning about me me learning about him
him learning about what it was like when
i drove like perfect environment
when he's telling me and we're just
looking straight ahead and when he's
telling me about smoking i'm like
smoking what and he's like vapes and i
just let i'm like what a different
[ __ ] world we're in you know
vapes is he talking about weed or
he says he's tried he's tried the weed
but he doesn't like it
um he doesn't smoke um he's not really
drinking he's
pretty straightforward kid but but these
guys that don't drink don't smoke don't
want a
[ __ ] a lot of people so you know it's
somewhere there's something out there
for everyone so we got to keep an eye on
if you're not drinking or smoking or
doing something you might be you might
be [ __ ]
coming out somewhere it's coming out
somewhere
i just i should always think to myself
what was god thinking
doing that to a 14 year old what was he
thinking
and when you know my one of some of my
favorite patients are my my
transgender female to males who get
exposed to high dose testosterone for
the first time
usually one of their first sort of
reactions is to apologize like i'm sorry
i didn't know
i i wow yeah they realize how powerful
that is what the influences you've been
under all this time and it's like yeah
and usually what i say is
yeah started when we were 13. yeah how
do you how do you think that felt
when you're just a walking you're right
you have no idea what to do or what's
going on
i mean i'll be straight honest i let's
see i was in
fifth but it was the summer between
fifth and sixth grade when i discovered
masturbating
i was on the top bunk my brother my
little brother at the time my mom
thought it'd be a good idea to put me
and my younger brother in a room
and my twin brother in his own room and
quickly realize i should keep the two
that are going through the same [ __ ]
in the same room but i didn't even know
what masturbation right i was just
laying listen i remember in the sex
education courses in the 70s i
i couldn't understand there between
menstruation and masturbation
with two m words that's all i can figure
out
but i laid on my back and i just was
touching it
flicking it and all of a sudden this
thing happened and i was like
oh my god i broke it everything no i i
was scared but it was amazing
yeah and then it was every [ __ ] night
until i was
48 years old um until
every night until the stage friday it's
thursday night
and i mean to this day it is a foolproof
sleep aid for me if i can't get to sleep
i'm knocking one out and i'm
i'm done i go back to the spank bank or
whatever and boom i've been fortunate
enough to have some good memories
um so i i but i
it dawned on me i was in seventh grade i
tell you between fifth and sixth i i do
it and i'm just
doing this thing where i'm just just
sort of laying down and cat pawing the
[ __ ] thing i don't know any i don't
i'm
and i know that like after an hour yeah
something happens
that's it yes and i [ __ ] love it and
then one day i will never forget this
i'm not even part of the conversation
i'm standing in line waiting to get into
like math class at seventh grade and i
see these two guys
that i knew talking to one another and
one of them says something the other one
goes oh
and he does this and i not even in the
conversation from the back of the line i
see the grip and i think
oh my god that's it i can't wait to
[ __ ] get up
eureka the half of the day i changed the
grip on my dick
why am i not grabbing it like that oh my
god
but again embarrassed to ask anyone
and there was no jerkoff.com i could go
look at you know now you can get a
tutorial on how to make a woman squirt
yeah how to get [ __ ]
all of it everything their average age
of exposure is like age 10
11. it's crazy 10 or 11. yeah
it's so easy to get well it just it just
you if your kids on the screen
assume they're getting exposed to it
yeah just it's just well my daughter was
playing this damn garfield game on and i
watch
and they do this told me about that yeah
they do these ads in between and it's a
[ __ ]
a girl that walks in there's a her
friend and her boyfriend are in a shower
silhouette and it's like what would you
do i'm like what the [ __ ]
what is this i'll pay the dollar to get
rid of these ads
god damn i think that's in their votes
so they set it up how do you
like when you grew when you grew up who
did you talk to about sex
nobody no no your parents never sat you
down
not who uh was it taboo
or was it just figured out on your own
figure it out on your own i didn't feel
there was no i didn't feel any
pressure or energy negatively um
[Music]
oh i had a babysitter actually and i
think about it that i
had she was like a 25 year old teacher i
mean i was like you're gonna you're
gonna explain things to me
she's like no no no that's for your
parents i gotta explain how old were you
at the time
teens the early teens yeah twelve four
did she tell you
yeah she was pretty good about it it was
a very matter of fact and whatever and
it was like
i forgot i forgot i didn't put on a spot
i
drilled i was like we are not gonna this
i'm gonna say you rate me
no no but it it was good it was that was
at least so i got some
some information you know but it's kind
of why we're
one of one of the things that demoted me
to do a loveland there was no sort of
place for people to go and at that point
it was urgent because we had hiv going
around
right and uh and i was listening to dr
anthony fauci
at the time who was encouraging us young
guys to go out there and educate
and uh i was admired him a lot in 1984
and uh took him around a long time
he was a big deal during the aids
epidemic yeah
and uh so yeah so i started just
answering questions i
there i i also had a really terrible
experience in college when i started
getting depression anxiety in terms of
how i was managed and treated and stuff
was really bad
and there was no adolescent health at
that time and there was and there was
weird stigma around mental health and i
just thought that that's insane
and then it's pretty easy to understand
these things and veneer and infectious
diseases
sexually transmitted diseases were
shrouded in latin and they're called
venereal diseases and
yeast infections were called manilises
and it was just unnecessary
and i just thought we is there an easy
concept anybody can understand it i'm
gonna answer these kids questions and
that's it yeah because it is it's
frightening as [ __ ] to see
to see if you if you see something on
your body that's not usually there you
get scared everything's scared scared
sure sure and and it's it's you may not
know what it is because you have no
clinical experience with it but to once
you
get a diagnosis to explain somebody
here's what that is here's how to avoid
it
here's what you need to do with it it
makes it all very simple and now there's
google and they
you know they don't need me so much that
i mean i say it all the time you don't
need parents
you gotta
but i do wish i had the internet when i
was a kid i would have absolutely
known more than i you know again the
internet put us
all back 10 years yeah they realized the
information age hits and you're like
god yeah and so there there are i think
advantages you're right and there would
have been
definitely distinct positive things that
could have come of it and will come of
it but we
had all sorts of liabilities that we're
trying to manage and understand now
still
so good times my friend
dr drew give me in a time that um
i mean how were you when you got when
you were finally exclusive
what age exclusive your wife because you
said you knew each other oh
we dated for like eight years before we
we
were exclusive for periods of time up to
a year or two within that eight years
uh and then we'd sort of break up oh i
see okay yeah
yeah and uh
at the end it was like okay this is like
there's something here and this is like
ridiculous i can't but it
can't shake yours you couldn't shake it
well my the eight years was not about
her
i i knew that there was something there
with her the eight years was
me being just men have this thing where
they when they're not ready to get
married they are not ready
and hannah and she was ready and sort of
forcing the issue and that was that's
what would break us up
oftentimes what shifted for you
uh i got old enough i finished my
training was sort of out in the world i
just want to know who i was in the world
before i could make a big decision like
marriage um and i was ready i was just
ready it was just different
and i was and if we had we done it
earlier it would have been fatal it
would have been
absolutely you know asking what what
makes a lot more this you got to be
ready
make it's not even it's not just about
the person it's about being ready
where you are in your life okay yeah
yeah that's very important
well look i know we got to get you out
here you got to get all the way over to
pasadena oh my god i wish i'm sorry
so i was i i just been doing this local
news broadcast on
fox on fox 11 which is not not fox news
it's the simpsons family guy that fox
and uh
it's right over here on bundy you know
and i thought oh it's perfect i'll see
ryan i'll go yeah 1999 south bundy i
know exactly i used to work in that
building that's where i'm at my
daughter's mother
in that building wow that's crazy how
about that across from lamps unlimited
or whatever
that's it that's the building right on
arma cost or whatever it is or
uh what's that i don't know i can't
remember the bill in the street but
but he it uh i thought you know i'll
head right up there after sickler and
then it's like oh no i
because i got back from new york a week
and a half ago or a week ago
they're making me not come back to the
building for 10 days not sure it's silly
i'm getting i'm new
and i'm amused i've had coven but i get
it
it's the policy so here we are well
thank you for being on again
website drop it all that yeah drew.com
if you sign up at drew.tv we'll give you
a blast out when i do streaming shows
which i do on most days
all right and um after dark which you've
kind of been on it will be on again no
download so
a lot of fun working with those guys i
know they're the best
well thank you man uh as always ryan
sickler dot com
uh ryan sickle on all social media we'll
talk to y'all next week
[Music]
you